ciao ragazzi benvenuti in quello che è
molto probabilmente un blog che non
facevo un blog dal 1992 più o meno sono
qui per parlarvi di una cosa che per me
è molto importante per voi forse sarà
molto meno d'impatto però lasciate che
mi spieghi avete presente tutti quegli
youtuber che sfruttano il loro pubblico
per i loro intrallazzoni personali e
anch'io ho deciso di fare la stessa cosa
chi mi segue assiduamente lo sa già il
mio sogno è sempre stato quello di fare
comicità dal vivo
non so se quello che voglio fare io sia
stand dato è se sia cabaret e non lo so
voglio semplicemente un posto dove dire
sono state alla gente è sperando anche
di farle ridere magari ed è qui che è
nato peli pubblici mio monologo che ho
scritto in un'idea di quanto dure io
spero duri intorno a loretta ma
probabilmente durerà 2 minuti e poi ce
ne andiamo tutti a casa per i pubblici è
il mio figlio deforme quello che dovrò
mettere a posto col passare degli anni
ma che comunque prima o poi dovevo far
vedere alla gente ed è il motivo per cui
sono qui a fare questo video siccome
comunque voglio iniziare a fare stand
dato devo comunque provare a vedere se
ne son capace perché potrebbe esserci
anche l'opportunità di fallire in questo
progetto e quindi peli pubblici sia che
un bel nome proprio per portare la
famiglia a vederlo e lo spettacolo è un
monologo di comicità non ho idea si sia
satira non sia satira chi se ne frega io
ho qualcosa da dire quindi lo dico ed è
vietato ai minori di 16 anni
semplicemente perché alcuni argomenti
sono trattati in maniera molto esplicita
quindi ho deciso di metterlo vietato il
minore di 16 anni e quindi sono tagliato
l'ottanta per cento del mio pubblico
il monologo dovrebbe durare un'ora
appunto come ho già detto secondo me è
dura molto mettendo però comunque è una
prova
al massimo se durerà venti minuti gli
altri 40 li passiamo in allegria insieme
tanto nel prezzo è compresa anche la
consumazione ci possiamo ubriacare
dimenticare tutto quanto quello che
voglio farvi capire però che questo non
è un raduno non è una sessione di
autografi
non è una fiera voi lo state venendo
vedere io topi voi state venendo a
vedere a rim
questo è quello che ho sempre sognato
guarda quando avevo 15 anni e voi me ne
date l'opportunità spero solo che la
gente che venga a vedere il monologo sia
la gente che realmente interessata a
quello che ho da dire
ho già fatto dei test per vedere se
riesco a stare nel palco e se la mia
memoria non non mi uccide quando sono
andato al video game show di napoli sono
stata una cinquantina di minuti a fare
un monologo ed è stato molto bello e
molto emozionante nonostante comunque il
pubblico non è che fosse così tanto
interessato alla fine perché era una
fine sui videogiochi mi ha dato
l'opportunità di farlo io l'ho fatto
ovviamente è l'ambiente proprio
sbagliato per farlo è quello che voglio
fare io non ha niente a che fare con le
recensioni non ha niente a che fare
tanto meno col gaming e sono
semplicemente io che ho qualcosa da dire
e non voglio dire a qualcuno che vuole
ascoltare quindi se volete ridere oppure
volete vedervi fallire miseramente
schiacciato sotto il peso della mia
incoscienza tutte le info sul dopo il
come il quando e il perché e come per
una tale imposto mi raccomando fosse
solo una settantina
quindi se volete farlo il link e in
descrizione c'è scritto tutto dove come
quando perché questo è un po anche il
motivo della mia cadenza divido in
questi giorni perché la mia testa è
totalmente altrove ovviamente se questa
cosa dovesse andare bene io mi
mobiliterò per venire da da tutte le
parti possibili immaginabili per venire
a parlare a voi tanto questo assomiglia
vagamente al discorso che ha fatto gesù
dopo che è tornato in vita ma grazie
mille e ci vediamo 7